hi i'm david dobrik and these are my
firsts first prank you pulled on someone
oh i well this isn't really a prank but
i remember i told my mom once that i got
busted at school for for drugs and they
found drugs in my locker and she started
crying and I was like and then I let her
cry for a little bit and I was like I'm
just kidding I just I I got a D in math
and I go see like it could be a lot
worse and yeah she was mad about the D
but not as mad about me thinking her cry
for ten minutes
that was my first pray sorry mom first
kiss whoo coming soon I was 13 17 it was
under this like gazebo and it was a
super plan it was we were like I was
talking to this girl and I was like I
was like we're gonna kiss so we had like
this whole plan and like and we were
like yeah then we're gonna make out and
I'm gonna touch your boobs and I was
like this whole thing and I was 17 I
know I've guys talked like that but yeah
it was very sloppy there I remember I
remember was freezing out so like my
snout was running and Hearst I was
running and it was just disgusting and I
pulled away because we were like making
out and I was like this doesn't feel
right and she goes it's not like the
movies it's kind of gross but it was
it's very memorable first memory that
comes to mind of the vlog squad it has
to be the first day I met Zenon Heath I
went over to the apartment they were big
Viners they had a lot of money and they
were just like living it up in LA I
called my parents I'm like everyone's
rich here and it was insane to me I
called my friends and I was like yeah he
is like I just went out to dinner and he
spent a hundred and twenty-five dollars
and I didn't have to pay for any of it
that that was like one of my first
memories was like whoa like what are
these kids doing and then it all went
away because vine ended
first time you met Jason Nash the first
time I really remember meeting him was
at a comedy club he was doing his like
stand-up gig this is when you're still
doing stand-up and he was really funny
and I
asked him if he can come back and do the
same thing he did on my vlog and the
next day he came over and we filmed and
then ever since that he came over every
day and we just been filming ever since
first vine my first pine was um I think
I was at a grocery store with my mom or
I was at my brother and I remember it
was horrible first youtuber friend
that's tough I'm gonna change it to
first vine her friend Jack Dietrich the
guy who works here Jack come here this
is Jack he actually helped me with funny
he works here in Val he helped me with
my first of I so I posted a vine this is
actually a really cool story I don't
know why he did it but I'm really
appreciative I posted a vine and he was
big on vine and I wasn't I wasn't that
big but at all he'd DM me on vine he's
like that vines really funny delete it
and repost it tomorrow and I'll revine
it and like he told me to post it at a
better time and I and back then you
couldn't like just repost vines so he
taught me like he like got on skype with
me and for 30 minutes walked me through
the process of how to like upload a vine
on to the app like illegally and then I
posted the vine the next day and he
refined it and he got another one of a
bigger vine or friends to resign it and
it did so well and it kicked off my
whole vine career genuinely kicked off
my career which is insane
thank you jack he didn't have to help me
at all but he did which is insane so
that's actually really cool thank you
the first day I've never like planned to
go on a date if like if a dates happened
it's been because I was hanging out with
someone and then I was like hey let's
let's go here instead now I don't think
I was ever like wanna go get dinner
tomorrow and then maybe see a movie
first car it's Maya Toyota Corolla 2004
Toyota Corolla the one of the best cars
at a cloth seats the the steering was
insane I drove it from Chicago to LA
when I moved here packed with two of my
future soon-to-be roommates and all
their stuff like my friend was a
musician so he brought out his guitar
his amp and was all it just filled in my
little Corolla and it's like what it's
one of my favorite cars first time you
saw your merch on someone that's a crazy
feeling when you see someone wearing
something you
I don't remember but I remember I
remember today today I landed at LAX and
we ran to a group of girls and one of
them was wearing my pink clickbait merch
and it's so so crazy seeing someone
wearing your clothes it's so
unexplainable cause it's like it's one
thing when a person comes up and sees
your video but then it's another when
someone has gone out of their way to
purchase an item to support you I don't
know it's the best that's the best
feeling first memory of moving to
America my first memory is we were
surprising my mom I flew over by myself
when I was six and my dad told my mom I
was coming in like a couple days later
so my dad picked me up at the airport I
was in tears because I flew by myself
and I was so scared and then we drove
over to the apartment where my parents
were living at and my dad went in first
and I waited three minutes and I knocked
on the door and my mom answered and I
remember just her like I remember like I
was here I remember her looking right
over my head because I was like this
small and then she looked down she was
like oh that was that's like my first
memory that was really cool looks yeah I
did a nice very well and then I made her
cry first time you were recognized in
public
I remember when like it first like I
first started you recognized not my
closer friends but like a lot of my
friends in school would be like you set
that up right like they would think I
remember when there was there was like a
fan account that had like my name I was
like david dobrik something and everyone
at school thought that i made the
account and like six or seven kids would
come up to me that why did you make that
account and I swear to God I didn't I
remember I remember the first time I got
recognized for my vlogs that was big
because it wasn't for it wasn't for my
vines and I was on Hollywood Boulevard
and this girl walks up to me she goes I
love your vlogs and I was getting like
7000 views a video and I go why you
watch my vlogs and she's like yeah no
one's come up to you and I was like
you're the first person to say that
you've watched my vlogs that was nuts I
was on my way to Buffalo blinks first
thing you do when prepping for a new
video I wake up and I look in the mirror
and I go
can you do this no I don't know I just
wake up and I get going yeah that's it